mr. Minister Miller there are already
exchange programs for Germans and
Africans what exactly is going to be
different about this one as a grunge
that basically we don't know enough
about each other we need to bring
together young people from Germany
Europe and Africa the African continent
is 100 times the size of Germany with
three thousand languages and a huge
variety of cultures peoples and
landscapes I'm the lab the field fault
couture may I want to get young people
in Germany excited about getting to know
the continent i plump because done Xenia
it's already happening in many other
ways such as through schools higher
education and especially the cultural
aspect and through athletic
organizations about the spot when
there's no me again let's look at it the
other way around say I'm a 16 year old
student and Benning what do I have to do
to take part in the initiative in
Germany park under stuff we have partner
organizations we're starting with three
countries and one of them is ben een
after a selection process the chosen
young people then come to Germany and
young Germans go to the African partner
country we're starting with three
countries and I'd like to expand that to
other parts of Africa too but I need
help from the communities in Germany
Ophelia Umbra the association of German
cities supporting the initiative
understood throne patch with our
thoughts on coumadin the Dodgers the 300
partnerships that we have will grow to
1000 on but I wound up and we're going
to get other states in Germany excited
about it too the Bundys lenoir-rhyne
Westphalia has a long-term partnership
with Ghana and Ryland pods has a
partnership with Rwanda this project
will have a ripple effect raked the
prize it seemed a steal my identity the
goal of the initiative is to overcome
challenges like climate change and
combat world hunger isn't that too
ambitious for young people I'm some of
these kids are really young yd you
mentioned are innocent it skipped
volubly there are two questions of
survival for both
africa and the world one is securing
nutritional we could eradicate world
hunger especially in Africa AFRICOM one
thing has to be clear though the world
population grows by 250,000 people every
day it's Posada Africa the population of
the African continent will double in the
next 30 years that means people
especially young people need food amirul
Abaddon [ __ ] see then there's the
question of work for them ugh so come
Africa needs 20 million new jobs for
young people each year million Albert's
bit that's a challenge about film but
also an opportunity even for Europe and
Germany Ozzy all fear or it'll pas don't
feel dog it's not about talking it's
about doing or even some time to deposit
the politicians need to work on new
levels dimension it's also in our own
interest from interested if we don't act
now we'll end up paying a high price for
a total price per ton one sign is the
movement of young people from the
African continent looking for new
perspectives human madness African dish
incontinence is new iron signal with
most modern you mentioned migration
there's a lot of illegal migration
should we be worried that some of the
Africans will use the opportunity to
just disappear after the project no we
just have to develop structures late we
have to be the bridge that people can
cross from both sides in the past years
we've developed one-sided exchange
program as it started for example 5,000
students from Cameroon are studying in
Germany cameroon in deutschland very few
go back bring their experience and
newfound knowledge back to their own
country I'm as mostly handle that needs
to change you have to be able to cross
the bridge from both sides young Germans
as well as German companies have to go
to Africa and vice versa we have to
develop relationships and freaking Thank
You minister danke Schon